okay so maybe not
everything is the fault of movie studios
[Music]
hey there everybody it's that time again
where i like to talk about lgbtq plus
related
elements of entertainment media and
this is actually going to be a bit of an
addendum
and an additional expansion on a rather
old video
so two years now i can't even remember
but a while back i did my video
on um well it wasn't queer baiting in
the sense that most people use it but
what it was about was
when filmmakers and studios tout
inclusion
in things and then don't actually have
it there
examples at the time included jk rowling
claiming that
dumbledore was gay without it ever being
in evidence even in the newer fantastic
beasts movies
the claim by one of the writers of solo
that
lando was pansexual when there was no
clear evidence of
that lefou in the beauty and the beast
remake being claimed to be gay when
there is at best a vague hint
at that and nothing definitive that
can't be ignored by anyone who chooses
to ignore it
and a ton more beyond that when i say
i'm sort of touching back on that same
thing
what i mean is that
this perpetuation of
talking up representation
to the point that it feels like it is
overshadowing
the film and it feels like these studios
are
making a bigger deal out of instead of
just letting
lgbtq plus people just exist just be
there
not make a deal out of it the thing is
it's not always the studios making
the deal while i stand by that previous
video and all the examples i mentioned
in it it's worth noting that most of
those
including the few that i cited as decent
examples of how to do this properly
largely came out in interviews
these weren't press releases even
even like the incredibly offensive back
padding session that was
lefou with his exclusively gay moment in
beauty and the beast
that wasn't a press release that was
something that came up in an interview
now i can and do still argue that in
that case director
bill condon and in most cases you know
these writers producers directors etc
should just keep their mouth shut and
let the representation speak for itself
if it's even there but
what will happen is first off
if a reporter
article writer whoever is conducting the
interview
thinks there's something there catches
with
of there being any kind of inclusion
they know that's a story
or they at least know they can treat it
like it is one and they will try and
tease that out
of these people still their fault for
talking they're professionals they
should know how to do this
but it becoming a story
it becoming the headline out of the
article
that is the fault of the media
talking about it because you can have
someone like bill condon give a
full interview about all these aspects
to this movie that he's made
and he mentions one thing about a
character he claims to be gay
and that person he gives the interview
to then goes up
and writes with a big banner headline
gay character in disney film
that wasn't what the point of the
interview was
it wasn't the primary focus it wasn't
what was talked about the most but they
make it the headline that is a choice
not of the director the writer even the
studio that is a choice
made by the outlet reporting it and this
is how media outlets well it's one of a
number of ways i'll talk about some
others that media outlets
contribute to this problem now they
don't
create the problem the problem of
representation and failures at
representation either bad representation
tokenism
baiting a representation that is not
actually clearly evident
all that is existing problems but the
way in which it gets reported the
prominence of it and it
signal boosts things that compound
the problem here's another good fairly
recent example
so the pixar film onward which i have
seen
and it's fine that
film has in it a lesbian character
it is one of the police she is talking
to another character it's not worth
going into everything
going on the scene but she's talking to
another character and she mentions
her i can't remember if it's wife or
girlfriend
but you know she talks about that and
it's
very casual it comes up very natural in
conversation and i would actually say
that's a fairly decent bit of casually
referenced representation
that confirming it and dropping it into
the
conversation in a way that felt natural
and unforced and fit the scene
yeah oh it's pretty solid but i was
frustrated because i already knew it was
there going in
not because pixar had
trumpeted that it was in there
but because once reviewers started
seeing the movie
they spilled the beans on it and made a
story out of it
whereas the studio and the makers of the
film
didn't bring it up so far as i could
find themselves at all
prior to release they may have been
asked about it but they were not the
first ones to bring it up it was brought
up by reporters who knew about it
once reviewers started seeing the movie
in other words the issue that i would
have with that situation
which is the fact that it was headline
news
that there is a gay
in a pixar the fact that that was big
headline news
is what ticks me off not the
representation itself in that specific
instance
and in that case and not only that case
but that
is a very clear-cut and easy for me to
express to you case
of the outlet
making it a story the studio didn't do
that
the movie didn't do that but it ended up
as a story
anyways because the sad reality
is that
this is a way in which the media cycle
and the way that it is in perpetual
motion
around the production of these big films
and that cycle is always hungry for
content
about it now usually this
works to the advantage of the studios
making this
entertainment disney and marvel have
really mastered this because you know
they
they will drop something as innocuous as
just a title
for a film and they know that the entire
geek film related media is going to
start
doing all these speculation pieces about
what characters will be in it here's the
history of these characters in the
comics here's what might be in the
in the film it's and then next little
nugget that they dropped whole
same thing again but where that
ends up being used for
evil to be slightly hyperbolic about it
is when
they take something that is not
meant to necessarily be part of the
media cycle
but because they know it will get them
clicks
be they clicks from people who are in
favor of this
and want to support it or clicks from
people who are outraged at it and want
to find out what they should be angry at
it's a headline
and it is very very easy especially in
something like a pixar a disney
animated family film marvel star wars
dc anything that is considered
family entertainment
trying to incorporate these things
even if they don't do what i have yelled
at them about which is to
preemptively pat themselves on the back
talk it up ahead of release
and like be all look how inclusive and
progressive we are
even if they don't do that it's still
going to feel like they did
because as soon as the media finds out
about it
which at the latest possible time will
be the instant a reviewer sees it
then it's going to still feel like that
happened anyway because the same
headlines are going to happen
the same articles the same people
writing
about whether or not this is sincere
representation about whether or not this
is the end of western civilization
because it's there about whether
it should be boycotted about those
morons who say they're gonna boycott it
all those spins all the stakes will
happen regardless simply because
we exist in
a piece of media heaven forfeit
that there be somebody
who is not cisgender heterosexual
oh my goodness and especially in
something like onward with like it was a
cyclops
there's a world with centaurs and elves
and manticores
but there's a lesbian in it make a
headline
the media is part of the problem and
that's not going to go away because
they're going to write what they think
will get them clicks and get them
noticed and get them
stories and the only way that's going to
get better
well there's two ways that will get
better one is to simply not include
lgbtq plus characters ever again and if
you are
even considering that as an option
[ __ ] you number two
is to include us often enough that we're
not newsworthy anymore
i've talked before about how
the fewer instances of representation
there are the more noteworthy they
become
these are headlines because they are
exceptions and they're unexpected or
they're
boundary breaking or what have you
but if you know we were just present
in enough media that nobody
was making a deal of not the makers not
the characters in the films and
whatever media would eventually stop
writing about it because
that's not news anymore oh
there's a trans character in a
dreamworks movie
that's not news who cares
oh that's my dream world right now
someday okay so i don't have a sponsor
for this video
however in the space where normally a
sponsorship drop
might go i'm instead going to highlight
a creator
who i think people who watch my stuff
would enjoy and appreciate and for this
one i want to highlight
someone who actually has two channels
the
youtube channel shipper's guide to the
galaxy which
is about fandom shipping and also
casually comics the same creator for
both she is absolutely wonderful and
delightful she is
just a joy to listen to to hear her talk
about these things that she loves
she is updating more regularly at this
point on casually comics you can tell
that that's
uh sort of a bit more where her head's
been at lately but both are worth
checking out and i do
recommend them whatever your thoughts on
anything that i have just said
leave them down respectful please in the
comment section and let's talk about it
the usual stuff to do you know what it
is like subscribe i have a patreon of
course i do
you can help me out on that any amount
is very helpful but even if you're not
able to do that the like the subscribe
and sharing this around
are all big helps so thank you so much
for
listening and until next time this
council
is adjourned
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um